this is volgen Colonel can you hear me
yes folga we need to move on to part two
of your faq series you'll be asking me
use your submitted questions right
exactly just one thing try not to screw
up the pronunciation of people's names I
can't guarantee anything Vokoun okay
I'll cover the most commonly asked
questions first what software do you use
I use adobe audition cs6 Reaper which is
free from their website and melodyne for
specialized projects how do you create
voice effects for individual scps sorry
but I've told you all the software I use
already so you can experiment it find
out for yourself if I can do it so can
you are you part of the SCP containment
breach development team ever since I've
always some characters and the recent
release a lot of people seem to think of
as part of the team which isn't the case
I simply got approached by red Ulis and
it gave me a script I post on the forums
now and again with so can anyone else
I'm no more involved in any one at this
stage okay now on to individual user
questions quotes M PI asks what training
if any have you had for your voice
acting I've had no training I've been
copying voices my whole life the only
difference is now is I'm a little more
creative and I post them online Natalie
blank asks what's your favorite a CP I
think it has to be SCP 668 the chef's
knife I just find the concept super
creepy and terror
Lucas fila asks where did the name
volgen come from if I'm honest I can't
remember I think it was a superhero name
for a character I designed as a teenager
could shoot electricity from his hands
and volgen was a compound word between
volt and gun jeremy wilson asks who is
your favorite voice actor voice acting
inspiration there's so much amazing
voice over talent out there I think my
all-time favorite would be Steve Blum as
he voices some of my favorite all-time
characters also david hayter robert
price asks do you play video games I do
yes although not nearly as much as I
used to the last thing I played was far
cry 3 blood dragon which was awesome
okay that about does it good now where
do i get up
Vogon what's wrong Logan very turn